brotherhood of steel are the guardians  of human civilization  fort atlas is safe it came at a great  cost  the brotherhood must stand united  the super mutant threat takes priority  this proves more than anything  the need for our justice  you're splitting our forces shin the  most important thing is finding  everyone that has gone missing and  returning them home  [Music]  so it comes to this  i thought you understood what that  insignia meant  you are no paladin of the brotherhood  i set this plan in motion and i am the  only one who can stop  the brotherhood of steel must protect  the future of appalachia  and of the world your righteous crusade  has gone too far  while it may seem that we are fractured  i believe that we are now stronger  than ever  this is a choice that can never be  undone  [Music]  you